okay well we have a phone call we got a
phone call and we have Blake who I
believe is a soldier at Fort Bragg ooh
yeah this is Mike on the line Blake you
call me doctor I gotta call you by your
title what are you one one officer one
one officer one mister mister okay okay
no no he said yes okay so Blake what do
you have for me and Cory Neil please you
can't get this out of them my question
had to do with the gravity of the earth
if the earth had been born with twice
the size it up twice the gravity and
anything that evolved on the planet
would have evolved in that double time
gravity that we currently have is there
any upper limit to a earth-like planet
we're carbon-based life forms just
wouldn't have been able to evolve
because of the massive gravity that's a
brilliant question really yeah so a
couple of things if earth were sort of
twice our size we would have eight times
the mass okay because the volume goes up
as the cube of the thing so that's two
cubed would give you eight right so so
the surface gravity then is a
combination of health fart how much
farther away we are from the center of
the earth and how much extra mass is
there so you can do the math it but you
can just an assert making earth is twice
the gravity here's what will happen
everybody's legs would be more squat
first of all okay so we would everyone
would look a little bit more like a
hippopotamus all right
like Dorf you probably would wharfs
right you wouldn't things wouldn't grow
as tall giraffes would have thicker legs
horses would be shorter all of that
would happen okay the giraffe has very
high blood pressure to get blood to its
brain to go up to all the vert the the
vertebrae of its neck and so if you have
twice the gravity you would need twice
the pressure to get it up there and that
could blow your blood vessels so you'd
have a shorter giraffes so you wouldn't
have any of these tall creatures but you
didn't
about mammals you asked about
carbon-based life most of the biomass on
earth could care less couldn't care less
what the force of gravity was on earth
period all the life in the ocean is
neutrally buoyant that's right it
doesn't care
bacteria swimming in the pond in the pot
what he thought the the pond drop you
know you look at it when you're in high
school you look at other petri dish you
get a drop of water from the pond and
you see Paramecium in it yeah they don't
care about gravity that's right their
lives they thrive under like the surface
tension of the water so most life
actually does not care about gravity we
do because we're out here on the way out
here on the land we're trying to jump
Olympics would be kind of different you
know hurdling no there'd be the low
hurdles hurdles so yeah so sports would
be very different but a factor of two
gravity not a problem
for life right not and you'd have sort
of more sort of smaller life thriving
than bigger life and that's about it
Wow yeah Hado Blake so thanks Blake for
that one one just one follow up on that
last bit about from the the soldier at
Fort Bragg
he had asked about the doubling Earth's
gravity uh and I said ocean life
wouldn't care well I should have
commented water than weighs twice as
much so if you're accustomed to swimming
at a particular depth you then swim at
half that depth gotcha that way the
weight of the water above you would be
the same as it was in the previous birth
right for that's all okay straighten
that okay and they could easily find
that place right there fishes and they
move in three dimensions exactly are you
going right
[Music]